you
okay all right so just very briefly I
just wanted to remind you because it
goes along with the video
bioluminescence is light emitted based
on a biochemical reaction the most
common one is the enzyme luciferase
which reacts with a molecule called
luciferin to undergo a biochemical
transformation that uses ATP and as a
result of that transformation there is
light emitted so you don't have to shine
light onto these the light comes from
the biochemical reaction so the assays
and a lot of biological work is based on
the luciferin luciferase reaction so the
mushrooms that do this we'll have both
luciferase and luciferin so in a in an
organism you can Transpac cell or in
cells you can transfer with luciferase
and then when you're ready to do the to
see the lumen of the luminescence the
bioluminescence you can add luciferin
exogenously and there's a number of
chemists that are trying to make
modified systems that have different
light energies and so on so there's
there's a lot of protein engineering
that's taking place based on the
luciferin and luciferase pair there's
all kinds of cool biochemistry going on
now okay anyone who comes in you can
come and grab a doughnut we can move
them or do only doughnut okay all right
I didn't mean to call attention to okay
I want to go briefly back to arrays DNA
arrays because I want to explain to you
the power of this technology so last
time we were talking about arrays which
are basically printed layouts and I'm
this is going to be a very tiny array
with six sites on the array so it's a 2
by 3 array
the ones that are used in net in in bio
biology a way larger than that you can
see those up here far far more spots and
this is just the size of a glass slide
and at each of these sites there would
be different DNA sequences so there are
specific DNA sequences and they are
printed onto the array with a was
originally done just with printers now
there's more technological ways of
handling this and they're usually on
silicon or glass slides so there's a lot
of engineering went into the original
arrays to make these really pract
distribution of DNA's and these would be
what are called addressed arrays we know
what's at each of the sites whether
we're aware of the sequences at each of
the sites and there's really cool
chemistry that would have enabled the
disposition of these arrays so what
these are razing used for is to probe
complementary pieces of DNA so let's say
we've got F G H I J but come potentially
from genomic DNA and they complement
each of them complement one of the sites
on the change complement one of the
sites on the array but the DNA that
you're screening is specifically labeled
with a floor four okay so these would be
floor for labeled and what a raison able
you to do is to rapidly screen either
genomic DNA or actually much more
usefully as you all know now the
transcriptome so the messenger rna's and
I'm gonna remind you about technology to
take the messenger RNAs from cells and
then make them an appropriate copy of
the complementary DNA to what's on the
arrays so let's go take a look at the
next slide which describes the X
Barrowman so let's say you want to
screen populations of cells where one
set of cells is cancerous and the other
one is healthy you would collect the
lysate from those cells you would
collect the messenger RNA presumably
based on a tag or a feature of the
messenger RNA that's common to just the
messenger what would that be what would
be common to the mature messenger RNA
that would allow you to capture just the
messenger RNA not all the other RNAs and
not DNA anyone yeah
the poly a tail so you can with an
appropriate resin for example a poly T
support you can capture that all and
then in each case you would take the
messenger RNA collection and then what
you need to do is turn it into a
complementary DNA sequence we're much
happier screening at the DNA level
because the RNA is less stable so it's
really handy to do that conversion and
you use the viral enzyme reverse
transcriptase that's an enzyme that
comes from the retro viruses that are
exemplified by the HIV retrovirus that
we'll be talking about in the last week
of class so you'll learn where reverse
transcriptase fits in the life cycle of
the HIV virus
then once you've collected the the DNA
that's complementary to the RNA from
each type of cell you label them
uniquely for example with green
fluorophores or red fluorophores it's
kind of a global reaction you just
pleased chemically linked the
fluorophore to each set of DNA and then
you basically combine everything and
take a look at how the chips how the
arrays light up so that your typical
experiment would be everywhere you've
got something that has a red fluorophore
might bind to a unique site everything
with a green fluorophore
might bind to another unique site on the
array and then if both types of DNA are
binding to the same site that would show
up as yellow
if nobody is binding it would show up as
a blank spot so you get these
collections we're pretty easily you can
look at thousands of sequences to see
whether they're complimentary that's not
on your array everywhere you see yellow
the cancer cell and the healthy cell are
binding kind of equally so there's
nothing disease related there so that's
an interesting feature because you can
say well none of these are a problematic
segments but then you see very clearly
spots that are clearly red so the
sequences of the DNA on the glass or
silicon chip are complementary to
sequences that are unique to the mRNA in
the cancer genome in the cancer cell
line from that from that nice age is
pretty cool I don't know if any of you
hit that link but it's basically this
guy's sitting at a bench and doing an
experiment where he's able to do
thousands and the equivalent of
thousands and thousands of experiments
just by using one gene chip to do the
probing in other cases you will see
spots that are green which mean they
come exclusively from the healthy cells
so those would be really the ones you
want to interrogate and where it's black
nothing's binding so it's less important
so it allows you to go from a grid of
thousands and thousands of different
sequences to pick out suspects in a
döner disease related situation so that
makes sense
pretty cool technology the original
chips were called they were from Earth I
think Affymetrix they're athletes and
they are really widely used even to this
day and there are different types of
variations but I think one of the most
useful and ones that will remind you of
certain things we talked about in the
class is that you can grow the cells of
different sort of you know histories for
example you collect the messenger RNA
because remember the transcriptome is
much more interesting to us than
genome the chips would have to be a lot
bigger to skate scan all of the genome
and then you use reverse transcriptase
to make a DN a complementary DNA of the
RNA because it's more stable more
tractable to work with and then you put
on a fluorophore label mix everything
together and see what you get
so those are my candidate spots so if
you had an experiment let me think
walk you through what the arrays can do
but let's think make sure we know what
they can't do because it's always
important whenever someone says I've got
this technology it's going to solve all
the problems of the world throw away all
your beakers and test tubes you just
don't need to do any of that you can
solve everything with arrays so let's
say you've got a situation that in some
cases although genes may be defective
the messenger is still produced okay
so there's something wrong but you make
the messenger RNA so it would still kind
of show up normally on chip but the gene
defect could prevents translation into
protein so you get the gene but you
can't translate it so it's going to look
like a normal gene but it's in the
translation from the tracker from the
messenger RNA to the protein where
things go wrong
what what are you going to see on the
array is it gonna look healthy is it
gonna look
not healthy what what what what's going
to be the outcome could I use an array a
DNA array for this experiment yeah what
do you think
yeah yeah it's just gonna look like
everything binds to the chip it's not
going to be informative so in this case
you need to do very different
experiments that are at the protein
level all right so I want you to
remember that these are very good to get
the genomic sequence the messenger RNA
sequence but if you've got for example a
protein that is made and there's a
problem with let's say a phosphorylation
by a kinase that may be critical for
function in a Cell
you will not see that in the array that
will not be visible you'd have to do
different types of experiments for
example with phospho protein specific
antibodies to tell that there was a
disorder in those systems so always when
someone tells you I've got this great
experiment you say what can it do that
is awesome
but what can't you do okay I need to
worry about that all right okay so what
we've seen so far is we've seen a
variety of fluorescent tools for example
to label the nucleus either the original
atheneum bromide types of stains the
wool intercalate into DNA and give you a
fluorescent signal that could be seen on
a gel we've seen the evolution AB
aetherium bromide to less toxic
materials for example the Dappy stain so
Ophidian bromide intercalates ass idiom
sorry Dappy binds in the minor groove
and we saw images of that last time one
important distinction that is made with
these kinds of dyes is that Dappy is
what's known as a super vital dye
which means you can use that dye an
observed live cells so super vital is
associated with the types of experiments
that you can do observing cells that are
still alive
the Ophidian bromide is not such a dye
and neither are the antibodies because
so phillium bromide is toxic so even
though the Ophidian bromide gets into
cells it actually should have the H here
because it's specific that would be
ethyl bromide in my language so the
fillion bromide has the H there you
can't use that it's not a super vital
dye because it's toxic to cells because
it intercalates in the DNA and disrupts
replication so that is not super vital
so Dappy is this guy isn't and
antibodies which we learnt a little bit
about last time these are from my
description are simply reagents to
recognize components of biological
systems most commonly proteins and now
we're getting better at making
antibodies to carbohydrates for glycans
our antibody is super vital or not my if
they're not why can I use that on a cell
and follow a live cell with an antibody
yeah common
right so it's a correct they they're not
super vital what do you think would
happen if I add an antibody to a living
cell could it stains it could stain
something on the cell surface but it
might as you say interfere with the
function the cell let's say I have an
antibody to the epidermal growth factor
receptor that is gonna alter the
properties so you're correct in that
respect
what about targets inside cells so that
antibodies gonna get in yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's a big wall frankly it's a it's
an impenetrable barrier to get in so you
can really only stain and you can only
observe in what are known as fixed cells
and when we beat when we call a cell a
fixed cell we actually mean we've broken
it because what we've done is we've
treated a cell population with methanol
which pokes holes all over those
cellular membranes they're fixed they're
static on a slide they're not going to
move around anymore and you can stain
with antibodies you can tell what
happened at the moment what was
happening at the moment the cell passed
away if you will what was going on which
proteins were there you can't keep
observing moving forward because the
cells then are no longer viable
all right so neither of these approaches
are super vital but they're for
different reasons one is toxicity the
other one is also toxicity as carmen
pointed out but it's also a problem with
membrane permeability so what we're
going to talk about in the in the rest
of this lecture is a way to get around
this impenetrable problem and this had
these the discovery of the green
fluorescent protein
and we're really mostly about GFP and
its close siblings that might be
different colors what I want to walk you
through is the discovery of the protein
and I really want to impress upon you
how science happens in funny small steps
early on you could never have predicted
that a jellyfish off the coast of
Seattle was going to revolutionize
biology biochemistry life sciences right
whoo who would have ever thought of that
and so that's why you know I'm
colleagues we and our colleagues are so
excited about fundamental science where
you don't quite know where you're going
but you're working on something cool and
then the prepared mind goes Wow
that's interesting I could use that for
this problem
so Shima Mora was a Japanese of a
biochemist who was fascinated by by
jellyfish and their bioluminescence and
worked for years slaved away for years
and years apparently he would go with
his family to the small islands in Puget
Sound and have his kids go and collect
jellyfish all day long because he
noticed certain things about the
jellyfish that were rather intriguing
with respect to their properties and the
key thing that was observed was that
there is a bioluminescent protein in
jellyfish known as a Quarren so that's
the kind of luminescence we just
described but in the dark there was also
a fluorescence for fluorescent species
and it turns out that the light energy
from a Koren actually can excite the
fluorophore
in the green fluorescent protein and
then you emit the light at the
wavelength of the group in the in the
green so it was actually a coupled pair
of proteins a chlorine and the second
thing that he was just the green
fluorescent protein and what was
fascinating about this protein is more
and more work was done is that they
didn't seem to need any additives so for
bioluminescence you got to add ATP and
you've got to add
you know the intermet luciferin you've
got to add things to see the
fluorescence what was unique about the
green fluorescent protein is it didn't
need anything to add
you just had the protein and it was
fluorescent so what I want to talk to
you about is the molecular basis of this
fluorescent we'll also talk though about
the protein engineering that was
systematically done to make this more
and more of a useful reagent so Shima
Mora was the first person he had his
kids collect so many jellyfish that they
could extract the green fluorescent
protein through traditional old-school
biochemical methods and grow crystals
protein crystals guess what they're
bright green and we're able to solve the
structure once they had the structure
they sort of knew what was going on with
the jellyfish and they were also able to
recognize a particular part of the
sequence of the green fluorescent
protein that ended up being the
precursor to the fluorophore that we see
nowadays and we understand originally
the protein was not monomeric I'll talk
to you a bit about that later for
technology it's much more handy to have
this protein as a monomer not as a dimer
or a tetramer that makes experiments
complicated but I'll show you a very
easy trick that was done to fix that and
so the other people who shared a Nobel
Prize with Shimomura who by the way
passed away just a couple of weeks ago
in fact but there's an amazing old age I
must have been all that digging for
jellyfish that helped him live that long
there was also Martin Chalfie at
Columbia who demonstrated that the gene
for the green fluorescent protein could
be put in all kinds of other animals
organisms C elegans bacteria and they
would fluoresce and a really major
player in this entire story was Roger
Tsien who dropped died very young of a
stroke who was the chemist biochemist
who put the pieces together said if this
is GFP we can use it for so many
different things so he really advanced
the technologies of the
applications so protein expression could
be they realize quite early on could
just be programmed into a protein by
just having the DNA for the green
fluorescent protein stuck on to a
favorite protein of interest then you
would have that DNA be transcribed
translated in the cell and then your
favorite protein in the cell would
fluoresce green because it was attached
as a construct with the other proteins
so all of those things became enabled
quite quickly this could be done in all
all organisms eukaryotes prokaryotes
it's pretty non-toxic so expressing a
bunch of gene GFP in a Cell doesn't kill
it that's kind of handy so it really is
a super vital system and it's visible in
all kinds of tissues so what I'm going
to show you here are this some of the
seminal results first of all the
structure we'll talk about and then
Chalfie was able to put the DNA into
proteins in bacteria and also proteins
were labeled in C elegans and the story
of Chaffee is kind of funny he's one of
those guys who sort of didn't
necessarily have all the equipment he
needed but he knew this was really
excited and he needed a fluorescence
microscope so he would call up all the
companies who sold microscopes and say
I'm really thinking of buying this
fluorescent microscope this particular
one would be would really win these a
couple of hundred grand you know these
are not cheap things and he'd talk the
company into putting a microscope in his
lab for a month as a demo it's like you
know saying to the car dealer you want
to buy a car and then driving a Ferrari
around for months and then saying it's
not really gonna work for me so he
collected all these early data on
microscopes that were on loan from
Olympus and liker and various other
places so that's a funny funny twist
okay so the flora for all right so they
could go from DNA to protein sequence
then they could look at the structure
and see that the place in the protein
sequence that went serine
Racine glycine so here we go serine
tyrosine you recognize that one it's the
one with one of the aromatic rings
glycine is the one with no substituent
was common in a number of organisms
mostly aquatic organisms that fluoresce
and seemed to be the origin of the flora
for in GFP and so the chemists got to
work and you know what chemists do they
start drawing arrows and joining bonds
and figuring out how can we go from
something that's basically dead is not
got any fluorescence at all to something
that's fluorescent and so from the
structure and from working out the
mechanism they basically found that this
little piece this tripeptide within the
entire structure of the DNA primary
sequence was able to cyclize through
that nitrogen attacking that carbon and
then an elimination and then there was
an oxygen dependent oxidation to give
you this structure so if you look at
this you can still see the serine you
kind of know this was tyrosine but it
doesn't look like it anymore and it
turns out the glycine was incredibly
important it doesn't look like it's
involved in the in the chromophore but
when you have a glycine in a sequence it
allows you to do some funny twists and
turns because it has no substituents so
it allowed that loop to form once that
loop is formed chemistry can occur if
the glycine wasn't there things might be
not in an ideal situation to form the
Flores or the oxidation to put in that
double bond is oxygen-dependent so in
some cases the fluorophore would mature
a bit more slowly so you would go from
the pre state that's not fluorescent to
the fluorescent state quite slowly if
you withheld oxygen so a lot of
engineering was done to improve the
maturation time to improve the photo
physics there's really cool for the
physical experiments that were done but
that's the basis of it and the emission
of this flora for you can almost
recognize that it's a fluorophore
because it's got a lot of what's called
conjugation in organic chem
three one double bond another double
bond stack on so this ring was multiple
double bonds and in it emits at the same
a similar wavelength to the flora for
flora see so other people were happy
because all the filters on their on
their microscopes were the right ones if
you just use the fluoroscein filters you
would get a GFP seen so that that really
was made in heaven for those guys okay
so let's take a look at this here's the
wire diagram of the original
crystallized structure I've planted a
ribbon on there I get rid of all the
side chains so you see this beautiful
diamond structure let's throw away one
of the dimers and you can start to look
there's a little something sneaky in
there and as you get closer you can
start to see the structure there's this
sort of thread going through it so
that's just a trace of the backbone but
there is the structure of the
fluorophore here's the fluorophore with
a space-filling and what i think is kind
of cool is if you kind of twist the gfp
around it's kind of like a barrel and it
looks like a bird in a cage because it's
caged in there and to be honest it's the
structure it's not just the structure of
the fluorophore it's the fact that the
fluorophore is inside a kind of
hydrophobic environment that makes it
fluoresce I could go into the lab and
make that fluorophore and have it in a
beaker of methanol and you wouldn't see
anything it's only in that environment
is created in the GFP molecule so it's
fascinating the structure of GFP creates
the shape to cyclize and it creates the
environment for good fluorescence so
here's a mess of animals that have been
labeled with GFP as you've seen a mouse
has been labeled multiple times this is
was the first GFP rabbit he was known as
alba he even had his own name but
there's seaweeds and zebrafish and mice
from a litter C elegans the famous the
fly what else I don't even know what
these things are but purge inky cells
and so on anyway so this shows you the
you
Tyla universality of the tool one brief
mention about the dimer problem people
looked at the structure of the dimer
from the crystal structure and found
that there was a sticky face between two
monomers of gfp that encouraged this
quaternary structure and so they simply
changed to alanines that were sitting
right at the dimer interface one from
one monomer and one from the other
created a sticky patch it sounds a bit
like hemoglobin if you remember the
sickle cell hemoglobin they changed them
to lysines and baoyu was solved you had
just monomeric protein because when you
do a lot of experiments with gfp you
don't want gfp randomly dimerizes
because it's going to change the biology
of the protein it's attached to so this
very very easy structure driven
engineering was perfect ok so let's take
a look at some of the early things that
could be done now we take it all for
granted but GFP can be used as a
reporter gene to do a number of things
in in cellular systems so for example if
you want to study a regulatory sequence
to know whether this promoter works well
you can put it at the front end of the
GFP gene and then see if the promoter
works under certain conditions then the
GFP will be produced the cells will go
proudly green and this is a nice variant
to luciferase based system or a lag z
based system where you're actually
having to treat and fix things in order
to do the lac z experiments so here's a
really nice example with C elegans what
you could do pre gf and we really have
it's like a DBC you know ante or
whatever before before Year Zero and
after year 0 what the biological world
is pre GFP and post GFP frankly the the
impact that it's had on the system so
here is a C elegans as you know all the
neurons have names and a lot of C
elegans biologists are very familiar
with each you know single cell with
the c.elegans in particular the neurons
so this is a listing of the touch
receptors
you could have an antibody to those and
so you could do some antibody staining
but antibody staining remember we got to
fix the worms they don't like that you
literally fix them down and do the
staining with the antibody to get inside
the C elegans to see the antibody light
up the proteins you could do beat a gal
activity same thing but in both cases
these are dead C elegans they're fixed
they're in place you can't observe them
going forward but look instead that the
images you would get with GFP where you
could totally pick out all the touch
receptors and this is a situation where
an important protein in those cells MEK
17 is Co expressed with GFP and you can
see this beautiful image and the worms
are still alive you could totally watch
what was going on with them and he just
wants you to know that he's alive and
well and kicking okay now progress has
to happen so one green protein does not
a history make so immediately with the
identity of the structure of GFP I'm
going to go back really quickly to look
at that picture of the structure for you
sorry about this back and forward okay
the chemists realized that if they
changed this tyrosine to some of the
other amino acids that looked a little
bit like it like phenylalanine
tryptophan and histidine they might
alter the photo physics of this
structure because if you put tryptophan
there there's even more double bonds if
you put phenylalanine there that Oh H
has gone so there's really opportunities
and that's the chemist saying I can look
at this protein structure and I know the
one thing I can change is to change that
amino acid back at the DNA level so I'm
going to change the codon for tyrosine
to the codons for tryptophan
phenylalanine and histidine and then see
what my fluorescent protein looks like
okay does that make sense
so it was the one thing that's obvious I
can fix this
so what they did was they made the
series of GF PS and they transferred
cells and they were able to see that
when you replaced various residues for
example tyrosine to tryptophan tyrosine
to histidine there's a little bit of
variation here and don't worry about
this for a minute they were able to
create bacteria that had been
transfected with the mutated GFP s in
order to give them different colors of
bacteria so my question to you is if you
look at these this would have been the
original GFP except made a little bit
brighter by a small substitution which
of these would emit at the shortest
wavelength so just look at the colors
which is the shortest wavelength which
is the bacterium that expresses the
protein that emits at the shortest
wavelength you'd always be provided a
picture of the electromagnetic spectrum
yeah yeah the blue one exactly so you
can look at the spectrum and you say
okay I've got blue down here there's
that cyan it's kind of a blue green and
then I move towards the more yellow so
you can pick it out and say it's the
lowest energy it's the shortest
wavelength emission the highest energy
emission okay all right and these were
the variants that I just described when
I went back to the picture so you could
make a blue one with histidine you could
make a cyan one with tryptophan you
could preserve the green one with
tyrosine but a change in the serine or
threonine just improve the photo physics
long long story I won't are happy to
chat about it and in fact there was one
clever one where you couldn't really
make the protein yellow but if you had a
tyrosine nearby sandwiched with the
tyrosine in the GFP chromophore you
could actually go as far as a yellow
flora for
and that in principle should make
everybody really thrilled it's always
this situation with protein engineering
where you make something and it's huge
improvement and then everyone says well
what else you know what's next we need
red dyes we need all kinds of different
dyes so teams went back to the oceans
and actually collected organisms based
on the color they fluoresce that nice
way to sample things and actually we're
able to ultimately discover a red
fluorescent protein from the disk disk
ozma coral the original protein d s red
and if you look at this kind of
carefully it looks a lot like GFP
there's the tyrosine that funny ring
there's a double bond there but there is
an additional double bond down further
into the sequence that extends that what
we call the chromophore and when you
extend the chromophore you're more
likely to move to longer wavelengths and
that's how they got the red and then a
bunch of engineering later they got
what's called the fruits which emits at
all different wavelengths much of this
was not done rationally because they
went to nature they found out what
nature did they got here and then they
did a process known as gene chuckling
where they mixed matched portions of
genes to get them the entire color
spectrum they're not all fabulous
fluorophores they have some problems
they bleach easily and so on but
nevertheless this is a truly amazing
sort of outcome okay so and they enable
you to do art work with fluorescent
proteins with bacteria so you just paint
your picture and wait for the bacteria
to grow and you would have all those
colors so fluorescent proteins
originally were very limited originally
just green then blue green greenish
yellow but now with the palette that's
available you can color all kinds of
organelles in different types of colors
all right okay
so now let's take a couple of things
when we opened up this class we showed
you a bunch of these pictures because we
wanted you to stay in 701 six with us to
see the cool things you'd see and they
were they were pretty much what we would
call eye candy they look cool but how
did we make them and now with the
knowledge of GFP and RFP and so on you
can say okay I understand what this
experiment is and you can certainly see
that this is a super vital technique so
what I want to ask is what are we
looking at what is labeled to give us
this beautiful picture so you can sort
of go down and there's a bunch of
options but obviously anything where you
think you're labeling DNA with a
fluorescent protein is incorrect we're
labeling at the protein level we're
making the DNA to express the
fluorescent protein but we're actually
labeling a protein as opposed to DNA so
a and B are out for sure but as we go
through them you can start to see the
chromatin is red and the tubulin is
green so the outcome there would be
whoops what we're observing I thought I
what we were observing is that the
histones which are the proteins
associated with with chromatin are
labeled with a red protein and you can
see that there those are the chromosomes
and the tubulin these green fibrils is
associated with a GFP so C would be the
correct answer there and there's another
one of these cell division pictures once
again the same sort of idea but what I
think is really cool here is you can
literally see I love this picture
because there's this poor chromosome it
doesn't seem to be able to get with the
team he's hanging down there and
eventually just before cell division it
seems like things work out okay and cell
division happens now when you think of
this the capacity to watch this stuff in
action is really pretty amazing this was
another one there's a set of cell lines
where proteins in cell cycle are labeled
you had a question on exam three
proteins building up and going and going
away during parts of the cell cycle so
oftentimes the degradation of a protein
occurs when a protein gets labeled with
ubiquitin by a ubiquitin ligase and then
it gets destined for degradation so the
proteins that you're seeing grow up in
phases of the cell cycle are going away
because of the ubiquitin proteasome
system so in these cells particular
proteins have been labeled and here you
can see the phases of the the as the
components of the cell cycle as proteins
come and go through cell division and
you can literally observe where in the
cell cycle each individual protein is
why is this so fascinating I think in
therapeutic development is that you
could literally have drugs that might
impact aspects of the cell cycle and you
could watch them in real time impact the
imaging that you see on this screen with
the red and the green because if you
arrest at a certain stage in cell cycle
the cell will get stuck at a particular
color and you would even know which
phases which parts of the cell cycle are
being impacted so I think that's a
really sort of captivating way to think
of what you can do with these proteins
because you can see things in real time
dynamics of cellular systems and I think
oh and I am I'm going to finish a few
minutes early but I looked desperately
for a fluorescent Turkey and I couldn't
find one so I went with this light
string Turkey in fluorescent colors it
seemed to fit the bill
all right so please help us finish up
the bagels make sure you guys over there
get them and have a good break and then
I'm passing you back to Professor Martin
for Monday which will be a continuation
of imaging okay
you